una decisión histórica en materia de
migración colombia regularizará
temporalmente a los migrantes
venezolanos nosotros hacemos pública la
decisión de nuestro país
de crear un estatuto de protección
temporal en colombia
que nos permita hacer un proceso de
regularización de esos migrantes que
están en nuestro país la medida acoge a
quienes ya se encuentran en el país de
manera irregular que actualmente son más
de 960.000 los que ya están
regularizados no tendrán que acudir a
estar haciendo actualizaciones
constantes de sus permisos sino que
tendrán un proceso de mayor estabilidad
y a quienes están en nuestro país en
condición de irregulares tendrán una
hoja de ruta a esa regularización pero
con el fin de desincentivar la migración
ilegal quienes entren al país durante
los próximos dos años podrán acogerse a
la vigencia de este estatuto será de
hasta diez años y transcurrido este
tiempo los interesados en seguir en
colombia podrán optar a ser residentes
cifras de acnur señalan que en la
actualidad 5,4 millones de venezolanos
viven fuera de su país de esa cantidad
más de 17 millones viven en colombia
muchos de ellos bajo unas difíciles
condiciones humanitarias que el anuncio
de colombia de otorgar protección
temporal a los venezolanos que se
encuentran en su territorio por un
periodo de 10 años es un gesto
humanitario emblemático para la región
con usted existe inclusive para el mundo
interno según migración colombia a pesar
de la pandemia y el cierre de fronteras
se estima que diariamente más de 300
migrantes intentan ingresar de manera
irregular al país